hello and welcome to the Bleacher Report
fantasy football show presented by State
Farm my name is Adam Levitan I've
establishtherun.com joined by Mark
dankebring of establishtherun.com Mark
how's it going today
it's going great fun to be on uh in the
bleacher report app here I think we're
going to be talking about some players
to sell which is always an interesting
topic in fantas football and Adam you're
always one of the best people to talk to
about it so uh excited to be here today
shockingly the folks at Bleacher Report
have us back for week four if those you
guys have joined the show before
hopefully you know the format format is
going to be we're going to discuss some
players we think should be selling on
your fantasy football leagues we'll also
talk about some bundles some stacks for
this week that we like and we'll take as
many questions as we can from you guys
the audience because of course we're
here for you big game tonight though
actually before we get into it Mark I do
think I mean both teams saving players
for this game Taylor Decker back
tackleford the Lions Dave Montgomery
back Christian Watson back on the other
side Aaron Jones back
for the Packers as well felt to me like
they were saving all these guys for this
short week Thursday game to unleash them
anything you've taken tonight or
anything you like tonight
for the people
yeah I'm interested in betting Green Bay
here you mentioned they're getting
Christian Watson back also we're
expecting Aaron Jones to play as well
and those are you know arguably the two
most explosive players in the Packers
offense so I think getting them back in
the mix is helpful and and certainly I
like leaning into these home teams on
the Thursday night football games a
little bit of an easier transition from
them rather than you know Detroit having
to travel and play in Green Bay when I
think about this matchup in this game I
think back to I guess week 18 last year
when Detroit went there and kind of
spoiled Green Bay's hopes of making the
playoffs so this is a this is a really
interesting game I think um I do like
the Green Bay plus two just at home I
think this should be a tight divisional
game again like the players that they're
getting back so that's kind of my lean
on it at this point but certainly really
excited to watch yeah I think the Jordan
love stuff has been really good for
Fantasy real life I am a little worried
that Jordan love has been over his head
so far and could be a bit mistake prone
tonight and I do think he'll be Under
Pressure David back to Yari win on IR
for the Packers all right anyways we're
not here to talk about tonight's game
we're here to talk about your fantasy
football teams
again we're gonna go through some
players we think are worth selling right
now in fantasy football this doesn't
mean that you have to be selling High
necessarily doesn't have to be all guys
coming off good games there's a time to
sell low too before it gets even worse
and the first guy we're gonna talk about
maybe if it's in that category Mark
there Henry is coming off of a brutal
game once again got outsnapped by taji
Spears however that was against the
Browns so I don't want to say that like
Derrick Henry's totally dead this was a
very tough matchup against the Browns
however however
does not look good right now for Derrick
Henry getting up there in age ton of
mileage on his body taji Spears can play
Titans have arguably the worst offensive
line in the entire NFL
we've seen this before though where he
starts slow and gets going in the month
known as dehember what do you think
about selling on Derrick Henry right now
I would agree that that Henry is more of
a sell now and more of a cello as you
mentioned because he's averaging under
10 fantasy points per game so it's not
like people are are super eager to you
know go out and buy that production but
I do think people would still buy the
name value and you mentioned he got
outsnapped by Ty J Spears in week three
that also happened in week one against
New Orleans when they were in a trailing
game script and we just don't think the
Titans are going to be that great of a
football team despite having a ton of
respect for Mike variable and what he's
able to put together on the field each
week you know you mentioned his age he's
29 years old has almost 2 000 career
touches in the NFL and we typically see
running back production fall off a cliff
at these levels and again Derek Henry is
kind of a unicorn and how big and
athletic and fast he is but I do think
we're we're close to seeing the end here
for Derek Henry so I'd be willing to
sell early rather than you know waiting
and potentially it gets worse yeah and
the thing with Derrick Henry is it may
not even be him like he might not even
be in Decline but he needs a good game
environment he goes and he needs a good
team environment to do it and when they
get trucked like they did in week one
and like they did in week three I mean
he's just dead and so when this team
gets trucked if you think they continue
to get trucked I would consider moving
on from Derrick Henry sooner rather than
later
second guy on the list here is a guy
that man if people are paying attention
they are all in on Kieran Williams right
now I've been doing some of these uh
mid-season fantasy drafts mid-season
best ball drafts and I've seen people
take care Williams in round two in these
drafts like in the top 20 now now
I want to be clear if this usage
sustains for Kyron Williams
he will be a top 20 running back easily
and maybe a top 20 player because he is
playing every single snap for the Los
Angeles Rams he plays very well in the
past game as well and so I get that it's
scary to sell on the guy like this
however they just can't keep doing this
I mean less need the GM came out and
said we can't keep doing this
to Karen Williams and also
he's just gonna wear down man they have
on punt returns he he's he's pass
protecting he's running up the gut he's
running out wide he's catching a ton of
balls and they have his pun return
they're gonna kill this kid and so I I'm
not in the business of predicting
injuries but one way or another I think
the Rams are going to have to get
someone else help there so this would be
a market one for me if the market thinks
he's a top 20 player you can get
something like CD lamb or Jalen waddle
for Karen Williams I would do that if
people are like oh I don't even know who
Kyrie Williams is I've never heard of
this guy well then obviously you're not
going to trade him so what do you think
about
Kyron Williams rest of season here mark
well the knock on Chiron coming into the
NFL and kind of on his Prospect profile
is he's too small of a back to handle
this kind of workload He's listed at
five nine 195 pounds typically we see
NFL backs that handle you know Workhorse
roller or 210 pounds or heavier and so
it's rare to see someone at Chiron size
you know at least even get attempted to
given this workload by the ram so I
agree with you it seems a little bit
unsustainable I'm I'm much more willing
to sell and have PPR or standard formats
because he is such a valuable pass
catcher for the ram so in PPR I do think
he is an extremely valuable running back
to have right now just given how much
he's out on the field but certainly in
half PPR and standard formats I'm more
willing to sell high on Chiron again
just the usage is unsustainable here and
and we'll see how the Rams offense
progresses moving forward but yeah would
lean more cell and in those in those
types of formats and by the way I mean
Cooper cup could be back week five week
six week seven something like that and
yeah that might hurt Karen Williams
projected Target share but I think I can
keep cutback would also put them in the
Red Zone more and hopefully get Kyron
some more chances down there
third player to consider selling is
Jerome Ford now you guys all know people
in your league there's a lot of there's
a lot of box score Watchers in your
league right there's a lot of game log
Watchers and what they see
is Jerome Ford last week scored two
touchdowns what maybe isn't apparent
there is that Pierre strong closed the
game and Kareem hunt actually played
more than I thought he would in his
first game off the street so if we think
that Kareem Hunt's role can keep growing
a little bit and we think the matchup
won't always be as good as it was for
Jerome Ford this past week he could be
someone you could sell right now similar
to Kyrie Williams though you need to
have an educated owner an educated uh
enemy who knows
who drew before it is at least to start
before you try trading him so Mark what
do you think about this whole Ford cream
hunt split rest of season
well I think it's notable that cream
hunt saw eight touches on 14 snaps in
week three in his first game as you
mentioned so I'm I don't know if you
know obviously that that touch per snap
rate isn't going to continue but I do
think this is likely to be close to like
a 60 40 split in in favor of Jerome Ford
and
um you know I I'm I'm I lean more
towards holding just because
um
I do think the the pass game role is
good for him here the Browns have a
strong offensive line but they certainly
play in a tough division with strong
defenses and I think generally if you
want to sell a player it's all always
great to sell them after a two touchdown
game like you mentioned if people are
looking at the box scores so I'm a bit
iffy here um I would lean more towards
holding but you know I could see I could
see selling High here if people are
valuing him more is like a high-end rb2
or rb1 whereas I think he's more of a
low end rb2 going forward yep
I want to stick with Cleveland here for
a second I want people to understand
that Tennessee what's going on with
Tennessee is what we call a pass funnel
at establish the run this is when a
defense is very good against the Run
and is woeful against the pass so not
only
do they mute running back attempts and
Carries but they also really accentuate
Effectiveness and volume through the air
and I think that's what happened last
week with DeSean Watson DeSean Watson
had his best game I thought that he's
played as a brown however you know home
against Tennessee is like one of the
best spots he'll see all year it's
really hard to pull off quarterback
trades I think in one QB leagues but
like I certainly prefer Anthony
Richardson to DeShaun Watson rest of
season I certainly prefer to uh to
DeSean Watson I might even prefer like
Dak or someone like that
over DeShaun Watson rest of the season I
don't know I'm just scared that this
will be the best game that he has all
year and so if I drafted DeSean Watson
hoping that he would find his Houston
form maybe he never finds his Houston
form again but you could try to sell him
off this Tennessee game Mark what do you
think about that idea there on DeShaun
Watson
I think that's fair again timing is is
so important when selling players in
fantasy football and coming off this
Tennessee game I think is a perfect time
to sell as as you mentioned they do get
the Baltimore defense this week we
typically see these indivision matchups
be lower scoring and then the Browns
have a buy in week five and get San
Francisco in week six so certainly if
you're if you're waffling on pulling the
trigger I think now is the time all
right
let's get to some of the chat questions
here first one from Paul he says it's
Dave Montgomery and rb1 rb2 or a drop my
God Paul we can't be dropping Dave
Montgomery these running backs don't
grow on trees here buddy so we don't
know exactly how healthy Dave Montgomery
is tonight we are expecting Dave
Montgomery to play tonight through his
quad issue I think that the way that
they use Dave Montgomery before his
injury in weeks one and two is mostly
the way they want to use him he will be
the inside Runner he'll be a pass
protector he might only get one two
three targets a game but in today's NFL
nobody is a Workhorse back so I would be
still happy to have David Montgomery as
my second running back on my team
obviously there's going to be people
with better running back rooms than you
if Dave Montgomery's your second one but
hopefully you have a better wide
receiver room than them so yeah Mark
what do you think about David Montgomery
rest of season
he's an rb2 for me I have I have
Montgomery on a lot of teams so I'm
excited that he is me back to play
tonight and we've seen Detroit really
lean into the run early on in the season
at established around we do track teams
pass rate over expectation and right now
Detroit is in the bottom five in the NFL
they've been running a ton so I do like
that outlook for David Montgomery you
mentioned you know we expect him to
continue to be the workload or the
Workhorse on base down back uh base
Downs whereas Jamir Gibbs is more suited
to filling in the passing game so I do
think David Montgomery is an rb2
certainly in weeks where he doesn't
score a touchdown it's not going to be
you know an amazing famous fantasy score
most likely because he probably won't
catch more than one or two balls but uh
he's you know you mentioned it's hard
it's hard to find Workhorse running
backs in the NFL at this point so I
think he's certainly an rb2 moving
forward with how solid the Detroit
offense looks to be early on next
question from
ghxst he says Jordan love Anthony
Richardson or Deshaun Watson this week I
mean this one is an absolute no-brainer
Anthony Richardson with the way that he
runs and their pass rate and and how
fast they're playing it's just an
awesome setup for Anthony Richardson so
I think easy one there for you ghx
Anthony Richardson Chase Allen says PK
Metcalf Jamar Chase Jacoby Myers pick
three so we need to sit one out of
Metcalf Chase hookah and Myers
um certainly playing Jamar Chase here
they face Tennessee the defense that I
just talked about I'm certainly playing
hookunakua every time that Cooper cup is
out so then it comes down Mark to DK
Metcalf or Jacoby Myers you have to play
one of those guys this week what do you
think
these are all really good options so a
good problem to have I'll start out with
that
um I think you know in this situation I
would probably lean Jacoby Myers because
they're playing the Chargers which has
been one of the worst past defenses in
the NFL this season and just giving up
explosive plays left and right with and
with Vegas what we've seen with their
target distribution is just out of
control I mean they're pretty much only
throwing the ball to Devonte Adams
Jacoby Myers and Josh Jacobs as DK
Metcalf competing with Tire locket
Jackson Smith and jigba the running game
there in Seattle so I know it feels
probably bad just talent wise looking at
DK Metcalf and benching him over Jacoby
Myers but I think in fantasy Jacoby is
who I'd lean with there target tree is
so tight in Las Vegas we actually have
Jacoby Myers for 0.9 points more and he
came back half this week Robert Taylor
asks Derrick Henry or Raheem mostert I
assume he's asking about this week only
I think uh who would you start this week
Mark Derek Henry or Raheem moster
that would be most dirt for me Derek
Henry plays the Bengals who have a
strong defensive line again we've
mentioned the Titans poor offensive line
a few times already on this show and
most most dirt you know this Miami
offense I they're playing Buffalo and
that's the highest game total on the
week and just in fantasy we want to we
you know I think if you're deciding
between two players a a good
um you know distinguishing point is
looking at the game total for the for
what those players are in and Miami
Buffalo is the highest game total on the
week at 54. obviously Miami one of the
most explosive offenses in the NFL if
not the most so I would lean most hurt
there
all right Juan says should I trade Rahim
mostert for Alvin Kamara Alvin Kamara of
course is coming off suspension this
week we are projecting Alvin Kamara to
come back in and assume his lead role
who would you rather have rest of season
Mark moster or Camaro
that's really close I think depending on
your league format if it's a PPR League
I would probably lean Kamara because we
would project him to catch a lot more
passes throughout the rest of the season
and there's been some nice hype about
him working with the trainer in the off
season and regaining some of his
explosiveness that he clearly lost last
season so I think and PPR I would lean
Kamara and half PPR I'd lean most dirt
hopefully that helps a little bit yeah
for sure and again we do have rest of
season top 150 rankings up at
establishment and we have most dirt uh
four spots ahead of chimera that is for
half PPR
Pedro Pedro says should I trade Darren
Waller has not been a great start for
Darren Waller you know I saw people
taking Darren Waller ahead of TJ
Hawkinson late in the draft process and
I was like God
you know just on environment alone that
was I thought a little nuts now what do
you do with Darren Waller though I mean
what can you get for Darren Waller at
this point mark what do you think about
trading him
I'd say wait until they play Seattle
this week's the Seattle pass defense has
been horrible they're allowing over 330
yards passing per game this season so I
think wait it out one more week let
Darren Waller put up a big score and
then if you do want to trade him I think
his value is going to be a lot higher
following that Monday night football
game against the Seahawks
question from deberson Top
sorry if I butchered that Mr bear uh
says should I trade Josh Jacobs so this
is actually really interesting question
I know Josh Jacobs has been brutal
his role is incredible I mean nobody in
the NFL well other than the Rams doing
this weird stuff with Kyron and the
Colts doing weird stuff with Zach Moss
but no one in the NFL gets usage like
Josh Jacobs does even uh Chris
McCaffrey's gonna start losing work I
think like we saw last week it's Eli
Mitchell and so I am not trading away
Josh Jacobs who plays literally
90 plus percent of the snaps is involved
in the past game gets the goal line work
I'd actually be trying to trade for Josh
Jacobs not away
all right let's get back to some more uh
players to sell appreciate all the
questions from you all some more players
that we would be thinking about selling
if we had them now
James Connor is a guy who it's just hard
to see it it's just hard to see it
because he's not that explosive he's not
that fast team is so bad
however he just keeps producing I just
feel like uh Cinderella is going to turn
to a pumpkin or whatever the saying is
uh before too long before before too
long here and so on a team that I
understand they won I understand they
beat Dallas on a team that I think will
be out of the playoff hunt
come to the trade deadline it could get
even worse for this team at that point
so I think selling on James Conner right
now is an interesting play Mark am I
being too harsh on James Connor
I don't think so James Connor has been
really good to start the season there's
no no ifs and or buts about that but
right now he's averaging over five yards
of carry and on his career he's never
had a season over four and a half yards
of carry and his career averages 4.2
yards so he his efficiency is you know
really exceeding expectations I do think
the Cardinals look a bit scrappier than
we are expecting coming into the year
and and with them playing decently it's
I think more feasible that Kyler Murray
rejoins a team at some point but Conor
again the efficiency I think is going to
come down for sure in this offense so I
I would be selling high right now
next cell
is DJ Moore and
so he has cool Broncos this week right
and so this is gonna be one of the best
matchups that he's gonna get all year
yeah he may see some Patrick certain but
it's not that big a deal my concern is
that if DJ more fails against the
Broncos you'll never be able to trade
him and so considering DJ Moore is
coming off a couple of reasonable games
maybe you can find someone take them off
your hands this was a guy that we were
massively out on before the year because
of exactly what you're seeing play out
Justin Fields has not shown any signs of
being a capable NFL passer obviously
that's going to flow through to DJ Moore
so it's an interesting timing thing if
you're trying to sell DJ more here Mark
any thoughts on trying to sell him
before or after this Broncos game
yeah again timing's important he's he's
coming off a game against Kansas City
where he caught a late touchdown which
makes his box score look a bit better
and then he did get over 100 yards
against the Bucks the week before so you
have two good games to kind of sell to
your you know League mate that oh look
DJ Moore is still producing even though
the Bears have been you know awful
offensively overall so I do think now is
is probably a good time it feels bad
going against this Denver defense that
just allowed 70 points but again I think
that's more of a you know more of a
selling point in your camp that that he
could have a big week four and I think
still the rest of season outlook for DJ
Moore just with passing volume in this
offense is is pretty bleak so I think
now is is a solid time okay agreed Naji
Harris actually had an efficient game
last week anytime I see Naji Harris
having a fishing game I'm like oh like
let's tell the people we got to get them
off your roster now because the fishing
games from Naji Harris are not very
common he needs massive volume to get
there he's not going to get massive
volume because Jalen Warren is going to
play and play a bunch this year so
obviously Naja Harris against the
Raiders was efficient he's not gonna get
the Raiders every week yes he gets the
Texans this week which is another
good matchup but yeah I'd be trying to
get out from under Naji right now I
actually think that it's close rest of
season between Jalen Warren
and Naji Mark what do you think about
trying to dump Naji right now
yeah I would agree with you I think now
is decent time as well and with most
leagues being half PPR especially PPR
formats you know PPR scoring is the
standard on ESPN nowadays and so Naji
Harris is hardly running any routes or
catching passes from Kenny Pickett at
this point that role is all Jalen
Warrens in the third down and two minute
Trail so Naji Harris is going to get
base carries but that that doesn't
really lead to a lot of fantasy points
you know getting a Target is worth over
two times as much as a carry in PPR
league so I do think it is it is really
close between Naji and Jalen Warren in
our rest of season top 150 rankings we
have them almost back to back with Jalen
Warren actually slightly ahead so Naji
as a player we've kind of been out on
all year and I'll continue to take that
stance
last one we can do very quickly here if
anyone will give you anything for
Kadarius Tony at this point
I'd probably take it I mean
just not an NFL wide receiver cannot run
the routes that it takes to get open
down the field the NFL level yeah he'll
have some decent games maybe on Gadget
stuff maybe but the Kansas City chief
I'd rather let's put this way I'd rather
have her she rice right now than
Kadarius Tony uh maybe that's a hot take
but I think Rishi rice is ascending and
Kadarius Tony they're realizing it's not
what they thought they were getting when
they gave up a third round pick to get
Kadarius Tony
all right a couple more chats here
before we get to the bungles the bay
says what do you guys think the ceiling
is for Zay flowers so
I get that Zay flowers is not getting
the ball down the field his average at
the Target right now is five yards fifth
worst among all wide receivers however
however Todd Monk and I think sees a
flowers as a guy you get the ball too
quickly as an extension of the Run game
and when you get a bunch of those easy
looks
it just raises your floor ceiling combo
so much and so if we think Zay flowers
can maintain 25 even 22 23 of the
targets I think it's going to be pretty
good for Jay flowers the rest of the way
from Kobe bong's Mark he says miles
Sanders DeAndre Swift Zach Moss are we
selling these guys buying them or
holding them uh Kobe's putting us to
work here three guys sell by or hold
Mark we'll start with Miles Sanders
yeah that's an interesting list for sure
miles Sanders I would lean I don't know
it's tough because he is he is getting a
lot of the base down carries and then
his Target chair has been really strong
he got nine targets last week that's a
ton for running back so but in this
offense like the Carolina Panthers how
many points are they really going to
score I mean we saw that Andy Dalton was
an upgrade over Bryce young in week
three so uh you know kind of these
running backs in bad offenses are really
hard to show a ceiling in fantasy
football so I would lean more so to sell
off miles Sanders again the workload's
been great but not a good offensive line
not a great just offensive environment
in general DeAndre Swift is is uh tough
for me I mean I don't know he's like
he's looked amazing in the two games
that he's you know gotten the workload
obviously in the last two weeks so I
think you kind of just hold him at this
point and and you know are happy that
you're on her that he's on your team but
curious your thoughts are Adam that
that's a that's a really tough player
for me to evaluate no no no we've been
asking for this for four years give
DeAndre Swift a feature roll and see
what happens now that they've finally
done it
I'm not gonna bail they've done done it
oh I've asked for last three years is
for some coach to be like I you know
there's some flaws in the under Swift's
game but what he can do far outweighs
that and I think that the Eagles are
finally seeing that so no I'd actually
be buying DeAndre Swift as anyone is
selling the Zach Moss stuff I think is a
question of do you think Jonathan Taylor
is coming back to the Colts my take
right now is that it's gonna get ugly
and stubborn before it gets better but I
don't know what plays either team has
maybe they can work out a trade I don't
know it's not great for Jonathan Taylor
leverage that Zack Moss has looked
awesome while playing almost 100 of the
snaps two straight weeks and they've won
both those games it's not like oh well
if we get JT back we'll start winning
games like they're winning with Zach
Moss right now so yeah not a lot of
Leverage for JT I don't have a great
take but my point is just try to figure
it out what's gonna happen with JT and
that should give you an answer on Zach
Moss as of now I would lean towards
holding Zach Moss unless someone thinks
that like Zack Moss is the top 40 player
or something like that uh James says
should I start Jamir Gibbs and ramandre
or sick Gibbs and wait to see if saquon
is playing stake one Barkley described
his ankle injury as a high ankle sprain
this is one of the worst kind of
injuries a player can have however
the Giants claim that he could actually
play this week I don't know that I buy
that man and if he plays I think he'd be
a little bit limited so I would probably
go ahead and get Jamir Gibbs into my
lineup
tonight last one
yeah Steve says uh rank these for half
PBR a chain Montgomery for Jones I think
he's talking rest of season
for half PBR Devon a Chan I'm sorry I
struggle with these guys names so much I
finally got a chain right and then he
comes in and he says he wants to be
called a chance so anyways Han
Montgomery Jerome Ford or I believe
that's Aaron Jones rest of season who
would you rather have
yeah I think I'd have Aaron Jones at the
top of the list there just this Green
Bay offense we've we I mean AJ Dylan had
his chances last two weeks and looked
horrible so I think you know with this
with this offense under Jordan love I
like leaning into Aaron Jones area super
explosive um second I would probably
have uh probably David Montgomery or a
Chan there
um and then third and four or fourth I
guess would be Ford for me out of that
list yeah agreed okay
we're now going to move to everybody's
favorite portion of the program the
fantasy bundles presented by State Farm
where bundling your home and auto
insurance is just another way to save
with the personal price plan the idea
here is to figure out some stacks and we
talk about this in DFS all the time
obviously quarterback pass catcher is
very very correlated for anyone out
there playing DFS who or who wants to
play DFS understanding stacking and
correlation is a huge huge part of
playing tournaments the first bundle
that we have is Trevor Lawrence and
Calvin Ridley I understand that the last
two weeks have been really bad for both
Trevor Lawrence and Calvin Ridley the
margin of like success versus failure in
the NFL in these games is so small I
honestly think if Calvin Ridley had not
dropped these four balls and these were
balls not little flare outs these were
balls down the field in the end zone
shaky drops from Cavalry that he should
and normally makes if he had made all
four of those I really think there'd be
a different Outlook right now on Trevor
Lawrence and Calvin Ridley and so that
is
the first bundle there for this week in
the London game
second one mark why don't you talk about
Russ Wilson and Jerry Judy who have the
amazing matchup against the Bears this
week
yeah they play the Bears defense and
they're coming off this humiliating loss
against Miami where they gave up 70
points their off-season comments of of
Sean Payton you know criticizing
Nathaniel Hackett and the Denver
coaching staff last year being the worst
coaching job in NFL history and now the
Broncos are 0-3 heading to Chicago
facing arguably the worst defense in the
NFL so I do expect the Broncos to come
out and be aggressive here and really
try and answer last week's humiliating
loss so I I think they'll that means
they'll probably air it out a bit more
because you know they they paid so much
for Russ obviously they have talented
wide receivers and Jerry Judy and court
and Sutton but I think this is a great
week for Jerry Judy to get going it's
his third game back off off of that you
know preseason hamstring injury I think
he's going to round into form here so I
think this is a great stack to attack
this week against again what just a a
Bears defense that was bad to begin with
and have had lost some key members of
their secondary
third one is going to be on the Bengals
side Joe burrow and T Higgins already
talked about the Titans pass funnel one
of the best matchups that you can get I
think at this point if you are a
quarterback or a wide receiver is Titans
defense Joe Burr is a notorious slow
starter has also been dealing with the
calf
issue he looked well enough to me to
throw the ball 49 times on Monday night
and then you get T Higgins nobody's
going to want to touch T Higgins coming
off of another really ugly game there
for him on Monday night and so I think
getting in there with burrow and C
Higgins is one that'll be sneaky and
people aren't excited about but it's a
pretty good spot
fourth one Mark is one that everybody's
excited about or has been at least the
ram stuff what do you think about
Stafford and puka this week
I love it this week I just love this
game environment as well Pat thornman
who works at established the run and US
does a a pace and snapped column each
week in this game is firmly in the pace
up column both Indianapolis and Los
Angeles have been running fast-paced
offenses and throwing the ball a lot so
I do like the setup for Stafford and
pukunukua we saw you know the
Jacksonville offense shred this Indie
defense in week one we saw Houston shred
it in week two Baltimore didn't quite
get there in week three but I think the
LA Rams offense should be able to have
success here in the passing game and I
mentioned pass rate over expectation
earlier in the show the Rams are second
in the NFL and pass rate over
expectations so they want to throw the
ball a lot they're going to put the ball
in the hands of their Star Quarterback
Matthew Stafford so I I really like this
connection this week yeah I mean puka
didn't have his best game but he's still
caught
five balls you know and that was like a
floor game for puka is catching five
balls at this point pretty good last
bundle
Justin Herbert and Josh Palmer so
unfortunately Mike Williams blew out his
ACL
I also don't think Austin Eckler with
the ankle is going to make it back this
week and they're playing the Raiders and
so
you can it's hard to find a better setup
than Josh Palmer and Keaton Allen will
have this week I expect them to be very
past happy
I expect them not to throw the ball to
Josh Kelly it just opens up so many
targets
for Josh Palmer and Keith now and I
don't think you know Josh Palmer is like
a star it's not a great NFL wide
receiver so there's some risk there that
he's just not good enough to do it but I
think he's like League average or maybe
a little bit below and in this setup I
think that's enough for Josh Palmer to
get there
all right
a couple quick chat questions before we
get out of here today from Jay Fanny he
says should I start Russell Wilson or
Joe burrow this week these are two guys
we just talked about as having really
good spots I like both of them this week
Mark let's say you straight up for this
week Russ Wilson or Joe burrow
I like both of them too if Joe burrow
was healthy this would be an easy Joe
burrow answer for me but again kind of
the the situation I laid out for the
Broncos I really think they're going to
come out and be aggressive in the
passing game and Chicago's defense is is
so bad here so I I would slightly lean
Russell Wilson which is kind of crazy to
think you know uh if we if we ask this
question pre-season whether week four
would be starting Russ or burrow but I
think it's it's got to be Russ I mean
one thing about the Broncos stuff is
their defense is so bad also that
Russia's gonna have to keep scoring even
against the Bears like I think the Bears
are going to score points also so you
know should be a good game
from mamba Tyler Lockett or George
Pickens this week Tyler Lockett
or George Pickens obviously we know that
George Pickens has been seeing an
elevated Target share without Deontay
Johnson however comparing him Tire
locket as an actual NFL wide receiver I
think is a stretch what do you think
about this week Mark Lockett or Pickens
straight up
I think with Deontay Johnson still out
there with lean Pickens just because
there are more outcomes where he
probably gets eight nine ten targets and
just dominates the target share for
Pittsburgh again Lockett still dealing
with DK Metcalf Jackson Smith and jigba
and a little bit of a tougher matchup
against the Giants you know the Texans
defense while CJ shot in the offense has
been playing well the defense has
struggled outside of their matchup with
Jacksonville so I would lean Pickens
there
all right appreciate all the questions
from chat appreciate all you guys being
here as always for the Bleacher Report
famous football live show presented by
State Farm if you're interested in
following more of our work head to
establishtherun.com be sure you're on
Twitter at Adam Levitan at Mark dank
we'll be back next week well I shouldn't
say that assuming the good people at
Bleacher Report will have us back we'll
be back next week for more topics and
more questions to answer
four mark
four every behind the scenes at Bleacher
Report I'm Adam good luck everybody